toi sur ta commune tu as vu une
augmentation du nombre de fille
monoparental oui oui oui bien sûr et ça
c'est ça s fait petit à petit quoi avec
tout ce qui se passe actuellement quoi
faut avouer que tout ce qui s'est passé
toutes les crises qu'on a eu il y a des
familles qui ont entre parenthèses qui
on bien dérouillé quoi au niveau
national il y a 25 % des familles qui
sont monoparentales 40 % de ces familles
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté contre
11 % pour les autres
familles bonjour je suis Philippe brin
député de la 4e circonscription de l'URE
et je suis engagé pour améliorer la
situation des familles
monoparentales dans sa région d'origine
au cœur du département de l'URE tout
près de Louvier Philippe Brun a été
frappé par le nombre important de seul
avec enfants qui étai impliqué dans la
révolte des gilets
jaunes aujourd'hui député socialiste il
a décidé de chercher des solutions pour
ses familles monoparentales et il sait
où rencontrer certaines de ses mamans
solo bonjour bonjourjour ça
va ce jour-là au Secours populaire on ne
sait pas où donner de la tête voilà
c'est là ah voilà les per alors on va
laisser passer notre Michel on va
laisser passer Micheline parce qu'elle
est chargée c'est pas trop lourd ça va
voilà dans tous les produits qui
viennent de la Communauté européenne
nous avons 210 216 familles inscrites
sur les familles monoparentales on en a
74 74 sur 200 216 ouais c'est
énorme par rapport à aux autres années
on
est 10 % peut-être d'augmentation des
mamans solo toujours plus nombreus
d'année en année à l'image de ce qui se
passe au niveau national la France n'a
jamais compté autant de familles
monoparentales il y en a plus désormais
que de familles nombreuses mais surtout
ce sont elles qui sont sont les plus
pauvres en
France il y a 10 ans les familles
monoparentales avaient pas forcément
besoin d' scou populaire sauf pour les
vacances et tout ça mais pour
l'alimentaire pas forcément besoin
puisque ce que leur donnait la CAF et
puis autres leur suffisait pour vivre
alors que depuis ben le covid on s'est
aperçu effectivement que ces familles
avaient besoin et donc il reviennent en
force 30 % de famille monoparentale sur
sur un département c'est énorme quoi
avant avec 50 € je pouvais acheter de la
viande pour un mois là 50 € ça me fait
même pas une semaine et vous avez
combien d'enfants j'ai trois enfants que
vous élevez seul du coup oui seul depuis
toujours et vous touchez une pension
alimentaire en fait j'ai essay de
travailler au début donc en interrim
donc à C époque j'avais que un enfant
mais quand tu vois que tout ton salaire
va chez la nous c'est c'est un peu
compliqué à la on est en train d'écrire
une loi pour donner un statut au aux
familles monoparentales notamment aux
Mair célibataires dont vous faites
partie pour à la fois vous donner
davantage d'ê sociale et notamment un
droit de priorité aussi pour la garde
pour vous puissiez bénéficier V d'une
place en crèche avant les autres pour
que voilà vous puissiez plus facilement
reprendre un emploi dans 85 % des cas ce
sont les mares qui assument les familles
monoparentales dans sa vie une femme sur
trois fera l'expérience d'être seule en
charge de ses enfants au quotidien c'est
un combat qui évidemment un combat
social mais qui est aussi un combat
féministe pour moi c'est le premier
sujet féministe du pays c'est le sujet
des des mères célibataires de toutes ces
femmes qui se battent au quotidien et
qui peuvent pas travailler regardez
comme Madame il y a un tiers des
allocataires du RSA en France qui sont
des familles
monoparentales problème de moyen
problème d'isolement aussi car les mères
seul avec enfants p souvent une charge
mentale très lourde le risque
d'épuisement est réel pour ces mamans
solo qui ont bien du mal à avoir une vie
sociale c'est pour lutter contre cet
isolement que le vendredi soir jaridia
organise des activités
[Musique]
sportives 2 1 2 et on tourne ici les
enfants sont les bienvenus c'est trop
mou là on don tout
là
Philippe brin l'a soutenu pour monter
son association car la demande est
réelle bonjour Mons bien oui ça va
super les hommes qui sont là en fait les
TR hommes FA et mich
làbas
absolument s'app souci de ces femmes des
foisver gag temps et bienvent onarrive
pas se trouver du temps c'est parce
qu'on a les enfants donc là le fait de
participer à des activités avec les
enfants fait que bah tout de suite les
femmes répondent présentes et c'est
génial la question de F monoparental on
la réglera pas seulement par des
solutions
d'allocation l'amélioration du pouvoir
d'achat il faut évidemment mettre le
paquet sur l'accompagnement à la
parentalité et donner finalement à ces
femmes à ces hommes aussi il y a des
pères monoparentaux un peu de répi c'est
du répi dont ils ont besoin de l'
évolunelle d'épanouissement et c'est ce
peration jar très très heureux du
travail qu'elle est en train de faire
l'association ne se contente pas
d'organiser des cours de sport on crée
aussi des groupes de paroles où on
échange surtout sans tabou y compris de
la difficulté pour les mamans d'éduquer
seul leurs
enfants c'est vrai que nous quand on n
pas de papa on pas il y a personne qui
fait le rôle de papa on doit faire le
papa et la maman et on est des femmes on
n pas des hommes on ne réagit pas de la
même manière on n pas les mêmes émotions
on n'est pas pareil
donc c'est pas évident quand même à
tenir les enfants des difficultés qui
font écho aux annonces de la ministre
des solidarités et des familles Aurore
berger veut imposer des sanctions aux
parents dit défaillants en rappelant que
60 % des mineurs présentés à la justice
après les dernières émeutes était issue
de famille
monoparental ces paroles é un peu
difficile pour nous à entendre dans le
sens où nous sommes maman alors certes
nous avons toutes les responsabilités du
monde sur les épaules c'est pas que
simple ces propos nous ont un petit peu
choqué à partir du moment où nous sommes
maères nous sommes seuls nous sommes
forcément la cible de tout voilà c'est
on va pas lui souhaiter de le vivre pour
le comprendre mais il y a aucune mère au
monde qui souhaite que son enfant soit
en échec en fait quand ça commence à
chauffer que la jeunesse se mobilise
évidemment on a beaucoup plus de mal à
retenir son enfant quand on est au
travail par temp par sub qu'on travaille
la nuit quand on a gérer tout seul c'est
pas forcément facile de le retenir
toutefois
stigmatisoparental comme ça a été fait
évidment une erreur c'est pas en
rajoutant une peine à qui ont déjà la
double la trip la quadruple la quuple PE
qu'on va régler le
problème en plus d'organiser des
activités pour les mamans solo
l'association de jaridia veut participer
au débat pour les aider
financièrement
certes une procédure toute récente
permet à ces femmes de récupérer plus
facilement les pensions alimentaires non
verersé mais c'est encore une femme sur
trois qui pour l'instant n'en touche
pas la présidente de l'association veut
que le député aille plus loin dans sa
proposition de loi afin que ces femmes
profitent pleinement de ses pensions et
elle insiste sur un point qu'ils ont
déjà évoqué ensemble tu étais voir il y
a quelques mois la dernière fois qu'on
s'est vu on a on a parlé ensemble de la
question de la pension alimentaire
aujourd'hui c'est la femme qui reçoit la
pension alimentaire qui paye les impôts
sur cette pension toi tu en penses quoi
alors moi je trouve que je pense que la
pension alimentaire devrait être
défiscalisée pour ces femmes pour mon
cas je touche 120 € par enfant et ces
120 € là sont à déclarer et donc du coup
ça nous pénalise dans le sens où ça nous
fait changer de tranche euh d'imposition
en tranche au niveau de la CAF et donc
du coup finalement on y gagne pas
grand-chose voilà c'est voilà c'est
c'est justement pour cette raison que à
la semaine nationale dans le groupe de
travail transpartisan que j'anime on a
décidé de porter la proposition de
défiscaliser la pension alimentaire et
aussi de la retirer du revenu fiscal de
référence qui sert justement au calcul
des prestations sociales payer des
impôts sur une pension alimentaire est
d'autant plus incompréhensible les PA
déduisentes sommes de leur revenu fiscal
bon écoute merci beaucoup d'être venu
merci à toi le député socialiste va
également inclure dans sa proposition de
loi l'indexation des pensions
alimentaires sur
l'inflation une proposition qui ne peut
pas passer à côté de la question du
logement c'est la première difficulté
pour les familles monoparental
d'ailleurs une grande partie d'entre
elles vivent dans des surfaces trop
petites
Philippe brin rend visite au maire du
manoir sur scène qui essaie de dynamiser
sa commune sans oublier personne bonjour
danielon PhIP comment v-tu bon alors
c'est en train de s'aménager là donc ça
y est c'est sorti de terre c'est ça
c'est ça donc c'est mon fameux projet
centrebourg quoi on essaie de faire une
animation avec les commerces les
logements les écoles la crèche le narval
la mairie l'agence l'agence postale la
limite tout se passe là quoi et puis on
espère que ça va avir beaucoup de succès
mais j'y crois ça va être le centre
névralgique de la commune c'est ça dans
ce centre névralgique l'élu a voulu
aussi un immeuble de logements sociaux
là il y a y a 10 logements T2 T3 sur
deux étages sur ces 10 logement le maire
a le pouvoir de choisir les locataires
de qure d'entre eux et il ne les a pas
sélectionné par
hasard là sur C sur ces logements là on
a priorisé les familles monoparentales
personn qui sont en difficulté à la
limite c'est c'est ce qu'ils ont donc là
ça bah limite ça a bien marché parce que
j'en ai sur la commune donc ça c'est
bien passé j'espère qu'ils sont
contents les logements que j'ai pour
pour la commune pour les familles
monoparentales j'ai un exemple là au
premier étage où c'est une une dame avec
deux enfants bien sûr seule et qui qui a
une chance de travailler pour la commune
en tant qu' à l'école maternelle qui est
juste à côté pour elle c'est c'est bien
quoi elle a pas déjà d a pas trajet les
enfants sont tout prês il Mang à la
cantine donc je peut continuer à
travailler et puis à faire le nécessaire
pour ces enfants parce que c'était le
cas la guarde quoi cette initiative
le mérite d'exister mais Philippe brin
pense qu'il faut voir les choses en plus
grand donner la priorité aux familles
monoparentales mais pas seulement on
veut créer un nouveau un nouveau produit
de logement social qui soit
particulièrement adapté aux fé au
parental et qui permettent aux communes
aux bailleurs sociaux de construire des
logements pour ces familles qui sont
souvent en grande difficulté quand elles
se séparent on a auditionné un certain
nombre de bailleurs à l'Assemblée
nationale qui sont très intéressés c'est
un produit où on puisse mettre des FAM
parentales ensemble en vérité avec
parfois aussi des des lieux communs pour
se rencontrer partager et vivre ensemble
bah cette parentalité nouvelle qu' l'on
vit seul donc c'est des lieux d'habitat
partagés qu'on essaie de développer et
c'est ce produit qu'on essaie de faire
passer au niveau législatif à
l'Assemblée nationale une initiative
nécessaire pour les 2 millions de
familles monoparentales car avec un seul
salaire elles sont aujourd'hui fortement
discriminées pour l'accès à la location
dans le secteur privé Philippe brin
devrait présenter sa proposition de loi
en mars 2024 à l'Assemblée
[Musique]
nationale